Die Ligatour Europa ist wieder zurück. Wir wollen sprechen über die Liga, mit David Frogier de Pont-Lévin. Ja, ihr habt richtig gehört. Über La Liga mit Alex Troika, über die Premier League mit Uli Hebel, über die Serie A mit Christian Bernhardt und über die Eredivise mit Daniel Zander. Es wird höchste Zeit, dass wir loslegen.
Und nun im Programm, der Rasenfunk.
Der Blick auf andere Ligen.
Rest in Peace erstmal an alle, die das auf doppelter Geschwindigkeit gehört haben. Sorry, dass ich so schnell geworden bin am Anfang, aber ey, bei so vielen Gästen und wie schön ist es euch alle mal wieder hier zu haben. Wie immer mache ich das kollektive Hallo, hallo in die Runde.
Seitdem, seit dieser Aufnahme. Als sie immer noch sichtlos waren.
Genau, ja. Und zwar alle relativ spät. So in den letzten Minuten spekuliert man schon über eine Minion-Time. Wegen des Trainers Le Minion. Und ja, genau. Also, Ers hat nach dem SC-Spiel eine absolut wütende Brandrede losgelassen. Er hat den Charakter der Spieler kritisiert. Er hat, die würden sich zu schnell fallen lassen. Die hätten die Basics nicht verinnerlicht. Die müssten immer 110 Prozent geben. 90 Prozent reichen nicht. Hat mich teilweise fast an Streichelände, muss ich sagen. Und das fand ein sehr großes Echo in den Medien tatsächlich, in den französischen, weil das ist man für ihn nicht ganz so gewohnt. Der ist gilt eigentlich eher als als ruhiger, überlegter, sehr sympathischer Trainer. Man wusste auch nicht gar nicht so genau, was ist das jetzt? Ist das ein ist das ist das Wut oder ist das so ein Hilferuf von? Ich weiß nicht mehr, was ich hier machen soll mit den Jungs. Also auch da wieder so dieses, was wir vorhin auch hatten. Jemand möchte ein ein intensives System spielen, aber die hat nicht die hat nicht die richtigen Spieler dazu. Und das das das stimmt auch. Im Fehlen auch so ein paar da ein oder andere, der eben mal bei schlechterem Spielverlauf ein Team führen kann, unter anderem eben Dante tatsächlich. Also der jetzt auch schon seit zehn Jahren bei bei Nizza ist und eben eigentlich immer noch Kapitän und sie haben aktuell keinen Kapitän. Also Grüße an der Stelle an die Kollegen vom vom Sportcast dieses Spiel von Freiburg besprochen haben und sich gewundert haben, wieso hat denn dieser Bart da in der in der in der Verteidigung die Kapitänsbinde getragen mit seinen riesigen Fehlern, die er da zugelassen hat. Ja, weil es gibt keinen Kapitän gerade. Also die Kapitänsbinde wechselt. Zuletzt war es von Hute, der Belgier, der kam aber erst im Sommer. Dann war es auch mal Torwart Diouf, der kam auch erst im Sommer. Also wenn Leute Kapitänsbinden tragen, der erst seit vier Monaten da sind, merkst du schon, ok, irgendwas stimmt da irgendwie gerade nicht. Und ja, es fragt sich jetzt öffentlich, na ja, ist mein System doch zu ambitioniert? Müssen wir wieder zurück? Müssen wir wieder widerspielen? Aber das sollte das ja eigentlich nicht sein. Das sollte ja eigentlich eine Weiterentwicklung sein. Und ihr wirkt da so ein bisschen erschöpft und emotional und ratlos. Also da ist richtig Trouble drin. Und ja, also man fragt sich, was passiert jetzt? Ein paar Sommertransfers haben auch nicht gezündet. Auch dann an der Stelle wieder ganz interessant, weil das geht dann in Richtung Sportdirektion natürlich. Und Sportdirektion ist aktuell Florian Maurice. Der kam aber selbst auch erst vergangenes Jahr. Der hat ebenfalls den Ruf eines absolut perfekten Kaderplaners. Der hat in Lyon und in Rennes wohl gemerkt, hat ja großartige Jahre gehabt, war verantwortlich dafür, dass Rennes, ich sage mal, vierter wurde und sich da stabilisiert hat. Aber gut, auch da vielleicht liegt es wieder eben daran, vielleicht hat er gute Spieler geholt, aber die passen halt nicht ganz zum System des Trainers. Und das wird jetzt sehr spannend, weil nach der Länderspielpause steht das Derby an gegen Marseille. Am 21. November. Da wird dann auch das Stadion definitiv voll sein im Gegensatz zum Spiel gegen Freiburg. Das war ja ein Armutszeugnis. Wobei Marseille-Fans werden nicht da sein, weil die Behörden haben direkt vor der Reise schon mal angekündigt, nein, wir verbieten die Auswärtsreise. Mit sehr merkwürdigen Begründungen, unter anderem Erinnerungen daran, dass ja damals vor ein paar Jahren Nizza-Fans Marseille-Spieler angegriffen haben, wo man sich fragt, okay, aber wenn Nizza-Fans Marseille-Spieler angreifen, warum dürfen dann Marseille-Fans nicht nach Nizza? Also das ist nach wie vor ein problematisches Thema mit Behörden, Polizei und Auswärtsreisenden in Frankreich.
Hat ja auch der SC erfahren, das kann man bei 3.90 bei dir noch mal nachhören. Da hast du da ja auch drüber gesprochen.
Genau, genau, genau, genau. Und das liegt unter anderem daran, dass die Präffekten relativ viel Macht haben. Und die Präffekten sind anders, als wir jetzt in Deutschland halt vielleicht so im Kopf gewohnt sind. Das ist ja keine föderale Regierung. Die sind direkt dem Innenminister unterstellt. Das ist quasi eine zentralistische Institution und die kann ohne gerichtliche Beschlüsse, kann die beschließen, ja, da könnte was schwierig werden, wir verbieten das. Ich sage, das dürfen sie seit einem Gesetz, also sie dürfen es auch schon vorher ein bisschen, aber es wurde nochmal verstärkt durch ein Gesetz von 2011, das heißt LOPSI DEUX, wunderschöner Name, damals unter Sarkozy und das war ein umfassendes Gesetz zur Sicherheit. Es ging auch um Videoüberwachung und Digitalqualität und so weiter, also nicht nur um Sport, aber es gab einem eben auch einen Teil im Sport, der beschäftigte sich mit Gewalt rund um Sportereignisse, Klammer auf, Insert Football hier, Klammer zu. Das war sicherlich damals auch beeinflusst von den Ausschreitungen da in Paris, den Ultrakämpfen, wo ja auch tragischerweise ein persönliches Leben gekommen ist und eben auch im Vorgriff auf die EM. Aber da wurden tatsächlich sehr, sehr weitreichende Maßnahmen den Behörden an die Hand gegeben und die werden in den letzten Jahren immer stärker genutzt. Und das ist halt dann alles auch rechtlich und im Service-Fall sagt man sich halt, naja gut, ich hab das Gefühl, da sind Probleme, dann mach ich aber im Vorfeld schon mal den Laden dicht, dann kommen die Probleme erst gar nicht. Das ist natürlich alles höchst tragisch.
Absolut. Und da wird uns in Deutschland auch noch einiges blühen. Am 3. Dezember ist die Innenministerkonferenz, die inoffizielle, auf der auch weitere Maßnahmen gegen Fußballfans beschlossen werden sollen. Und das, obwohl sogar die eigenen hinterfragbaren Zahlen sagen, dass es sicherer geworden ist in deutschen Stadien in der letzten Saison. Aber das ist noch mal ein ganz eigenes Thema. Mal gucken, wann das mal wieder im Rasenfunk stattfindet. Also, Nizza gegen Marseille am 21. November. Das kann man sich mal zu Gemüte führen. Und dann werden wir sehen, ob es da jetzt in ruhigere Fahrwasser geht. Meine Erwartungshaltung– naja, wir werden nochmal sehen. Ja, genau. Spoilern, nein. Aber das tut es ja nie. Deswegen ist ja Fußball auch so schön zum Drüber sprechen. In etwas ruhigere Fahrwasser ist aber jetzt United gekommen. Und Uli, da müssen wir jetzt mal kurz drüber sprechen, weil United hat hier seit im Grunde Einführung der Ligatur immer nur negative Schlagzeilen gemacht in diesem Format. Und jetzt aber läuft es mal kurzzeitig zumindest besser?
Ja, nie besser. Also zu Ligaturzeiten nie besser zu Amorimzeiten. Fünf in Folge jetzt ohne Niederlage. Wir müssen ja nicht mehr alle Wettbewerbe dazu sagen, weil sie später nur noch einen spielen. Daher ist das relativ schnell erzählt. Auch wenn es jetzt zwei unentschiedene Folgen waren, jeweils mit zwei Gegentoren. Der Oktober war schon insgesamt gut. Hat auch den Manager des Monats– auch das hätte ich never ever gedacht, dass ich das noch mal sage– Rufem Amorim hervorgebracht. Den Spieler des Monats haben sie ja auch gestellt, mit Brian Mböhmow. Und damit ist es natürlich schon ein Name genannt, an dem das zu großen Teilen liegt. Aber im Ernst, also ich habe mir das jetzt noch mal, ich muss ja immer versuchen, das zu erklären, woran es liegt, dass es jetzt besser geworden ist. Und das ist okay, was die gerade machen. Also wenn das, auch das muss man noch mal einordnend dazu sagen. Ich bin deshalb glücklich damit, was gerade passiert, weil es natürlich vorher so bodenlos war, dass im Grunde alles eine kleine Verbesserung ist. Nichts desto weniger ist das okay im Moment. Wäre es das gewesen, womit Amorim von Beginn an aufgefahren wäre, dann wären wir alle einigermaßen einverstanden damit.
Aber wie spielt denn United? Das eine sind die Ergebnisse, das andere ist, wie sie zustande kommen.
Im Grunde ist das System, das hat er ja auch so vorhergesagt, immer noch das Gleiche, aber es ist schon in der Art und Weise ein bisschen anders geworden. Es gibt ein paar Hauptthemen. Zum einen sind sie ein bisschen direkter geworden. Das heißt, sie haben nicht mehr so viel nutzlosen Ballbesitz im eigenen 16er. Sie haben viel, viel hintenrum über diese 5er-Gette gespielt. Und jetzt haben die meisten Spielwechsel innerhalb der Premier League. Womit man ja schon sehen kann, es geht viel auf diagonal. Dann würde ich sagen, sind die Neuzugänge mitverantwortlich, dass das einigermaßen gut funktioniert. Also ein Beumot vor allen Dingen, weil das jemand ist, der diese Diagonalbälle gut aufnehmen kann. Breite hält, super erster Kontakt zum Tor zieht und so weiter. Lemmens im Tor, sehr gut, spielt viel, viel mehr lange Bälle, als Beye das vorher gemacht hat, der sehr kurz oft gespielt hat. Und United hat immer noch die meisten Torhüterballberührungen in der Premier League. Das heißt, das tut gut. Dann kommt Cesko auch ins Spiel, der mir viel zu schlecht wegkommt, insgesamt, auch wenn die Zahlen jetzt noch nicht so richtig gut sind, was das Torrischsten erzählt. Aber allein dieser eine lange Ball von Lemmens in Richtung Cesko kann vieles zum Positiven verändern. Sie haben so ein Mini-Workaround gefunden für Casemiro und Bruno. Bruno ist jetzt so leicht nach hinten gefallen in Systemen, dass er eigentlich nicht passt. Es ist auch immer noch so. Genau das Gleiche ist mit Ahmad, der jetzt auf der Schiene spielt und eben nicht mehr vorne. Und dadurch zumindest in der Offensive ein bisschen hilft. Da haben sie zwar defensiv dann das ein oder andere Problemchen, aber offensiv hat er einen weiteren inversen Spieler, den er ja so gerne drauf hat. Na, Amorim ist ja ein Fetischist in dem Punkt. Und dann gibt es noch so, also das sind jetzt so Sachen, die kann ich dir nicht belegen. Das ist einfach nur so der, vielleicht ist es aber von den Ergebnissen gelenkt. Ich habe das Gefühl, sie sind minimal sicherer in der Defensive geworden, sind ein bisschen aggressiver, sind ein bisschen mutiger geworden. Und sie sind etwas besser im zweiten Bälle aufsammeln, liegt vor allen Dingen dadurch, dass De Ligt oft ins Mittelfeld mit vorgeht. Und De Ligt in einer guten Phase kann ja immer noch ein richtig guter Mann sein. Das macht er okay. Das sind jetzt die positiven Dinge. Es bleiben aber die negativen und unter einer geschweiften Klammer steht da, sie sind immer noch brutal ausrechenbar.
Ja, okay. Und aber wenn du jetzt tippen müsstest, ich meine aktuell ist United siebter. Es ist aber so ein bisschen hinfällig über Tabellenpositionen zu sprechen, weil zwischen Tabellenplatz drei mit Chelsea und Tabellenplatz zwölf mit Brentford liegen vier Punkte. Also ja, aber jetzt eben davon gesehen, wo glaubst du ordnet sich United von der Stärke her ein?
Die große Frage ist, wie gehen sie jetzt weiterhin mit Rückschlägen um? Innerhalb eines Spiels hat es jetzt etwas besser ausgesehen, denn die sind nicht mehr völlig zusammengekracht, mit dem mal eine Aktion nicht funktioniert hat, wie in den Monaten zuvor. Sie haben aber jetzt zum zweiten Mal wieder zwei Gegentore in Folge kassiert. Und das halte ich immer noch für ein großes Problem, dass sie immer noch immer einen Punch kassieren können. Also wenn sie Platz sieben holen, dann wäre es Wahnsinn. Also dann würde ich das unterschreiben und sagen, das wäre tiptop. Ich kann es mir aber verfasst nicht vor. Also muss man von oben immer rechnen in der Premier League. Und da sind wahrscheinlich sechs Teams mindestens stärker und wahrscheinlich sogar sieben bis acht. Würde ich vermuten. Es dauert jetzt auch nur wieder eine gewisse Phase, bis dann der Rest wieder geschnallt hat, was sie jetzt machen. Und dann sind sie wieder exakt gleich ausrechenbar.
Das ist ja gut. Faire Punkt. Aber wenn es schon mal was Positives über Manchester United zu sagen gibt, dann soll es ja auch mal kurz stattfinden.
Darf ich kurz eine Frage zu United stellen? Weil ich sehe, Uli war beim Friseur, hat einen frischen Boxercut. Meine Frage ist, war der United-Fan denn endlich beim Friseur? Konnte er endlich die Tolle abschneiden?
Ich habe das gar nicht gecheckt, worum es da geht. Das haben mir ein paar Leute geschrieben, aber ich bin nicht...
Das ist seit einem Jahr ein Meme.
Es ging darum, es geht um einen Fan, der wollte sich erst die Haare schneiden, wenn United vier oder fünf Spiele in Folge gewinnen.
Ach so, dann darf er jetzt, oder? Ach so, dann gewinnt. Okay, dann gewinnt.
Und er hat jetzt so einen Afro seit einem Dreivierteljahr.
Ach so, okay, das tut mir leid, aber da bin ich...
Der Premier League Experte kriegt das nicht mit.
Das habe ich wohl... Also wir haben das jetzt... Nee, aber komisch, weil am Wochenende haben mich drei oder vier Leute geschrieben, dann kann der Fan immer noch nicht. Was für ein Fan.
Der ist ja so berühmt geworden, Oli, der macht für Paddy Power mittlerweile sogar Werbung.
Ach krass, okay.
Weil der hat natürlich seine Frisur so... Weil das so ein Ding ist. Also es ist wirklich geisteskrank, was der für eine Frisur hat.
Das ist aber auch ganz schön anspruchsvoll hier, ne? Also manche Fans sagen, ja, bis der Trainer entlassen wird oder bis hier und da viermal für ihr gewinnt. Also wie viele Vereine gibt es denn da?
Es gibt Leute, die wollen sich tätowieren lassen, wenn Trainer bis zum Jahresende da sind, ne? Also...
Aber damit ihr seht, welche Kreise das zieht. Celta Vigo, die ja selber nicht so gut sind, haben fünf Spiele in Folge gewonnen und haben diesen Kerl mit einer Glatze gefotoshoppt und einem Celta Vigo-Trikot so verringelt. Wenn du Celta-Fan wärst, würdest du so aussehen. So berühmt ist dieser United-Fan noch.
Das ist der Klassiker. Ab jetzt werde ich den andauernd sehen, ne? Andauernd.
Absolut.
Vielleicht habe ich es auch einfach nur überspielt. Ich weiß nicht.
Da müssen wir beim Match die Daumen drücken, dass sie noch zwei Spiele gewinnen. Oder was? Vier waren es? Vier?
Fünf sind es. Fünf.
Fünf, na gut, ja zwei Spiele.
Aber fünf in Folge ist ja wirklich gar nicht so leicht, ne? Ja, eben. Also da wird er in allen, wenn du nicht mehr in allen Wettbewerben bist.
Und sollen wir mal so sein. Haar wächst in alle Richtungen. Du hast das schon gut beschrieben. Die No-Win-No-Trim-Challenge, falls ihr es googeln wollt. Liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, ich, ach wisst ihr was? Ich packe einfach ein Link in die Show notes. Dann könnt ihr euch ihn angucken. Frank Hillett heißt er.
Und dieses Gesicht auf seinen Kopf Photoshoppen, wenn du das auch möchtest, in diesem Thumbnail-Bild.
Ja, ich würde mir eigentlich wünschen, dass Uli einsteigt in die Wette. Vielleicht gibt es einen Paddy-Power-Vertrag dafür, Uli.
Okay. Das würde hier zu Hause, zumindest bei einem Mitglied der Familie, für positiven Anklang sorgen, wenn ich dir die Haare wieder wachsen lassen würde. Aber ich kriege halt keinen Afro, sondern bei mir ist es dann eher, wie der Droger Willems immer so schön gesagt, zauerkrautartig.
Sehr schön. Sagen wir mal so, in diesem Haushalt hier gibt es ein Bewusstsein darüber, dass ich mal lange Haare hatte, aber ich werde immer noch regelmäßig dafür ausgelacht, weil sie mal bei den Großeltern ein Foto davon gesehen haben. Nun ja, das sind andere.
Pack das bitte auch in die Show notes.
Da wartet das Internet schon so lange drauf. Und es gab auch einmal…
Ich möchte die Haare als Thumbnail aussehen.
Also bitte, manche von euch dürften es schon gesehen haben. Mein Führerschein sieht immer noch so aus.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Jetzt werde ich immer rausgezogen. Ja, machen wir demnächst mal off-air. Jetzt blicken wir aber noch mal auf La Liga. Da gibt es noch ein kleines Thema. Alex, was ist denn da los?
Weniger La Liga mehr. Es ist ja International Break, also Länderspielpause. Deswegen ist es ein kleines passendes Länderspiel-Pausenthema. Also die Nationalmannschaft betreffend die Spanische. Es ist eine große Sache, aber für uns sportlich jetzt nicht so groß. Aber es geht um den Streit zwischen dem FC Barcelona und La Minia Mal. Der schwelt schon seit Monaten. Und jetzt wurde er wieder eingeladen. La Minia Mal hat ja Schamweinprobleme seit Monaten und kam am Montagmorgen zur Nationalmannschaft. Und danach kam der Ärzte-Report, der Befund des FC Barcelona. Der hat sich einer so nachschauen, invasiven Radiofrequenztherapie oder so unterzogen, also seiner Schamweinverletzung behandelt. Und der ärztliche Befund rät oder sagt vor, hier, der muss pausieren, der kann nicht spielen. Und musste dann wieder abreißen. Und dem Spanischen Verband hat das gar nicht geschmeckt. Denn der war ja schon eingereist, war schon da. Und die hatten das gar nicht am Schirm. Und dann gab es eine sehr, sehr erzürrende Pressebeteilung. Also sehr, sehr unhappierter Verband. Und auch de la Fuente, es ist ja in Spanien eh so ganggebe, dass sich alle gerne äußern bei Radiosendern, bei Fernsehsendern, viele Interviews geben. Also nicht nur die PK, sondern wirklich zu den Sendern gehen. Und de la Fuente hat sich dann zum Radiosender gesetzt und hat auch gesagt, ja, das schmeckt ihm gar nicht. Und sowas hat er noch nie erlebt und unprecedented. Und das kann nicht sein, dass es so abläuft. Und so schwelt dieser Kampf quasi weiter. Was ist der Hintergrund des Ganzen? Lamine Jamal hat seit zwei Monaten Scham beim Problem. Wir haben mehrere Spiele, ich glaube, Cole Palmer hat, glaube ich, das auch in England. Nico Williams fällt damit schon länger aus. Es ist immerhin eine schwierige, langwierige Sache, die du ja nicht einfach so behandeln kannst, sondern das zieht sich monatelang. Und Lamine Jamal hat das seit gut zwei Monaten, nämlich seit dem Länderspieleinsatz im September, Mitte September. Er hatte davor Probleme, konnte bei Barca nicht trainieren, wurde dann nominiert für die Nationalmannschaft. Konnte dort, weil er solche Schmerzen hatte, nicht am Training teilnehmen, wurde er aber in beiden Spielen der EM-Quali eingesetzt. Von 190 Minuten hat er, glaube ich, 160 gespielt. Unter Schmerzen, unter Einnahme von Medikamenten, ich glaube, eine Spritze hat er bekommen und hat das Ganze natürlich verschlimmert. Kam dann zurück zu Barca, konnte nicht eingesetzt werden, fiel aus. Und Barca hat das natürlich gar nicht geschmeckt. Hansi Flick hat sich negativ geäußert über den Umgang mit den Spielern bei der Nationalelf. Und so schweht quasi dieser Streit jetzt seit Monaten. Und jetzt hat Barca eben gesagt, ja, nee, unsere Ärzte gucken mal drauf. Nee, der darf nicht spielen. Und das schmeckt natürlich dem Verband jetzt nicht, weil das nicht sauber so vorab kommuniziert wurde, sondern erst, als er schon anreiste. Also das ist so ein kleines Thema, das aktuell die spanischen Gazetten und Medien so ein bisschen natürlich beschäftigt.
Ja, ich meine, eigentlich ist es natürlich gar kein kleines Thema, weil der Typ ist 18, hat unter Schmerzen spielen müssen. Es ist eh schon die Frage, wie viel Schmerzen sind eigentlich noch gesund, auch für Leistungssportler, wo Schmerzen nochmal was anderes sind als für Normalmenschen. Aber das ist schon relativ krass, wenn man sich das nochmal vor Augen führt. Und ob das jetzt dann mit dem Timing des Ärzte-Reports und so weiter, da kann man natürlich dann trefflich drüber diskutieren. Aber das ist ein sehr, sehr junger Mensch erstmal, eben ein bisschen mehr als 18 Jahre alt. Und da gibt es eigentlich auch eine Fürsorgepflicht. Ich sage mal so, der spanische Fußballverband ist ja zuletzt, egal ob bei Männern oder bei Frauen, jetzt nicht dadurch aufgefallen, gut organisiert zu sein, rücksichtsvoll gegenüber den eigenen SpielerInnen und so weiter und so fort.
Ich finde die Frage ist recht eindeutig, oder? Schmerzen sind nie gesund.
Generell ja. Natürlich ist das immer so eine Sache. Ein Verein hat natürlich seine Interessen, nämlich die Spieler möglichst zu schonen und nicht zu verheizen bei der Nationalmannschaft und die Nationalmannschaft hat ihre Interessen, die Top-Spieler einzusetzen, damit die Nationalmannschaft möglichst erfolgreich Fußball spielt und sich für eine WM qualifiziert. Da prallen natürlich Interessen und Konflikte aufeinander, aber wenn man eben weiß, dass Lamini Amal nicht trainieren konnte, Schmerzen hatte, trotzdem spielte und ich glaube, es war sogar im September das Türkei-Spiel. Da haben sie zur Halbzeit 5 zu 0 geführt in der Türkei und Lamini Amal wurde trotzdem nicht ausgewechselt, sondern erst in der 60. und 70. Obwohl er unter Schmerzen und Medikamenten spielte. Und das ist natürlich ein No-Go aus Trainer- und Vereinssicht. Und deswegen die Fürsorgepflicht von Nationalcoach de la Fuente und seinem spanischen Verband. Nicht immer optimal und deswegen verstehe ich völlig, wenn ein Spieler wirklich Probleme hat und er hat ja Schmerzen, er fiel ja auch bei einigen Spielen aus und wurde auch früh ausgewechselt. Also die denken sich das ja nicht aus. Der hat diese Scheinbar-Probleme, verstehe ich das völlig, dass du als Verein deinen Spieler schützen möchtest, weil ihn der Verband und Nationaltrainer eben nicht schützt.
Und es ist ein interessantes Thema, das auch Deutschland betrifft. Habt ihr das mitbekommen mit dem Frauen-U23-Team Deutschlands? Ich dachte es mir nämlich. Es hat nämlich nicht große Wellen geschlagen. Da wurde nämlich inzwischen bekannt und das ist verbrieft, dass wenn du absagst als Spielerin, du bist nominiert und du sagst ab, dann wirst du erstmal nicht mehr für die nächsten Länderspielmaßnahmen nominiert vom DFB. Und das ist nämlich ganz interessant, weil man da nämlich alle Komplexität dieser Fälle auch beleuchten kann. Weil im ersten Moment wirkt das total absurd, weil man sagt, was sollen Spielerinnen, die sich nicht wohlfühlen, müssen die jetzt– und da geht es ja zum Teil sogar noch um Minderjährige– müssen die jetzt quasi dann bestraft werden dafür. Auf der anderen Seite gibt es aber Fälle, bei denen tatsächlich Spielerinnen auch aus kleineren Gründen abgesagt haben. Also, was bekannt ist, ist zum Beispiel, dass jemand umgezogen ist in der Zeit und gesagt hat, ich kann da nicht, ich muss da umziehen und da kann ich dann auch den Verband verstehen, dass er sagt, es geht hier darum, ob du dich vielleicht irgendwann ins A-Team reinspielen kannst oder nicht. Und es gab noch andere Gründe, die sind allerdings nicht öffentlich kommuniziert, deswegen mache ich das jetzt hier an der Stelle auch nicht. Aber da gibt es nämlich genau die Diskussion und der DFB hat das quasi so gelöst, dass er gesagt hat, wenn jemand absagt, dann wird er erstmal nicht mehr nominiert. Welche Rolle da aber auch gesundheitliche Absagen spielen, dazu sagt der DFB nichts und das ist jetzt eine Diskussion, die müsste eigentlich hier in Deutschland mal geführt werden, aber ihr habt es nicht mitbekommen, viele haben es nicht mitbekommen.
Aber bei den spanischen Frauen war das rund um dieses rubiales Vergehen, das du vorhin glaube ich kurz angedeutet hast, Max, war das ja auch ein Riesenthema. Also dieser erzwungene Kuss auf, ich glaube, Jenny Hamosos war das, als die Weltmeisterin wurde, meine ich. Ja, und dann schlug das ja so krasse Wellen, dass ja die Spielerinnen des FC Barcelona ja die nächste Nominierung, als Rubiales noch im Amt war, boykottieren wollten und das nicht durften, weil ihnen vom Verband Sanktionen angedroht wurden. Also wenn dich die nationalen Mannschaften nominiert in Spanien, musst du kommen or else. Und die Sparserspanerinnen wollten eben nicht aus Protest gegen Rubiales und mussten aber, weil ihnen angedroht wurde, sonst werdet ihr gesperrt.
Aber im Gesicht des immer volleren Kalenders wird es ja immer mehr noch ein Thema werden die nächsten Jahre, dieser Konflikt zwischen nationalen Teams und Vereinen.
Ja bei Frankreich war es ja auch so. Bei Peer hatte er ja auch vor zwei Monaten, glaube ich, nicht so die Lust, mal wieder Quali zu spielen und hat dann mal ausgesetzt. Und jetzt kommt er mal wieder und dann muss es nicht unbedingt sein.
Ich dachte spontan gerade eher an den Fall Hakemi zum Beispiel, der jetzt bei Paris ausgefallen ist, für den aber ein Lebenstraum gerade in Frage steht, nämlich Afrika Cup in Marokko. Wo es jetzt heißt, Ode wird vielleicht Ende Dezember wieder fit. Und ich glaube aus Clubsicht wäre dir sehr lieb, wenn ein vielleicht wieder fit Spieler nicht direkt einen Großturnier spielt. Und gut, bei Olympia Mbappé konnte Real sagen, nein, ich glaube, da sind die Sachen nochmal anders.
Ist ja auch immer die Sache, wie reagiert der Nationaltrainer. Effektiv ja die letzte Instanz, die das entscheidet. Und bei Lamine Jamal ist er eben nicht happy drüber. Und vielleicht deschamp bei Mbappé hat gesagt, ja, kommen die zwei Spiele jetzt im September oder Juli oder was auch immer, dann verzichte du mal, sollst du dich ausruhen. Ist ja auch immer so ein Thema. Welche Umgangsformen herrschen da?
Ja klar, wie wichtig sind Freundschaftsspiele und so weiter oder Qualispiele.
Solche Sachen, ja.
Und ein kleiner medizinischer Beitrag noch. Schampeinentzündungen oder Pubalgia, wie sie auch in Italien spannen, extrem gefährlich, dass sie extremes Potenzial für Langfristigkeit haben. Also da gibt es in der Geschichte des Profifußballs viele große Namen in den letzten Jahrzehnten, die das dann jahrelang mit sich herumgeschleppt haben. Also das ist nicht was, was du vielleicht erst mal, ja, du hast eine akute Verletzung, pausierst vier Monate und dann bist du wieder da. So und das kannst du dir lange mitschleppen. Und gerade wie Max sagt, wenn es mit 18 schon losgeht. Das kann gefährlich werden für deine Karriere.
Tja, es ist einfach kein schönes Geschäft. Das Fußball-Business wird das besprechen. Das muss man echt sagen und auch an sowas magst du es halt dann. Aber gut, dann kommen wir mal nochmal in die Niederlande. Daniel, was hast du uns denn noch als zweites Thema mitgebracht?
Ich habe so einen kleinen Blick mitgebracht auf Twente Enthredder. Es ist so, dass von den größeren Vereinen in den Niederlanden, die in der Saison so ein bisschen schlecht abschneiden im Vergleich. Also wir haben ja neben Feyenoord, Ajax hier auch noch Utrecht z.B. oder Aset Alkmaar. Und da ist Twente aktuell auf dem achten Platz und damit hinter diesen allen. Auch Auftrag über Kroningen ist jetzt mittlerweile vor Twente und nach Nijmegen. Und das hat so ein bisschen auch zu tun, dass sie auch nach vier Spieltagen schon, eher fünf Spieltagen, die Träne ausgeschlissen haben. Josef Oosting, was ich sehr, sehr schade fand. Also der Start war stotternd, muss man sagen. Aus den ersten fünf Spielen haben sie vier Punkte jetzt geholt. Das war sehr unglücklich teilweise. Es war jetzt aber auch nicht so, dass Twente da zu Beginn irgendwie auseinandergebrochen ist. Das waren noch 2-0-2-1-Näherlagen, zugegeben wegen Zwolle und Excelsior und der Damm, also wegen Vereine, wo du da mindestens einen entschieden nicht holen musst mit dem Anspruch von Twente. Aber sie haben halt nur eins verloren und man musste sehr früh gehen. Das ist für mich eigentlich ein Beispiel für eine Traineranlassung, die zu voreilig war. Also ich habe Josef Rosting eigentlich mal sehr geschätzt, der kontinuierliche gute Arbeit leistet. Und, Klammer auf, könnte vielleicht ja auch ein Kandidat bei Ajax sein. Zumindest ist das so mein Kandidat, den ich mir gut vorstellen könnte. Klammer zu.
Wenn es den ergibt, dann wird es Ajax nicht machen. Sorry, dass ich es dir so deutlich sagen muss.
Ja, deswegen kommt er auch nicht. Schade, er ist Niederländer, er ist ablössefrei, weil er vereinzelt ist. Aber gut, das ist ein anderes Thema. Ja, dann ist es auch schon so, dass unter dem neuen Trainer jetzt, unter John von den Brom, Twente eigentlich einen Traumstart seitdem hingelegt, nämlich drei Siege in Folge geholt. Und dann auch die Offensive, die so ein bisschen gelahmt hat, wieder belebt, auch gleich ein 5-2-1 gegen Sparta oder Damm erzielt. Und von den Brom hat so ein bisschen gegen den Trend gearbeitet in der Liga. Also viele Teams lassen dieses 4-2-3-1 jetzt spielen. Und von den Brom ist es zurück zu einem 4-3-3, hat die Fokus mehr auf Risiko gelegt, mehr auf Offensive gelegt. Und das hat sich zuerst ausgezahlt. Aber jetzt scheint auch wieder so ein bisschen der Motor wieder weiter zu stottern. Es gab auch viele unentschiedene Fanierenlagen wieder. Und vor allem durch diese Risiko-behafete Spielanlage auch wieder mehr Gegentore. Gestern 3 Tore gegen Neymich und beim 3-3. Dann das schon erwähnte 2-3 gegen Ajax mit 3 Gegentoren. Und gegen Groningen dann auch nur 1-1. Aber auch wieder mit Gegentor. Also es hat sich quasi verschoben. Bei Oosting war es zuletzt in den ersten Spielen keine Tore erzielt. Dafür aber ein verhältnismäßiges Wien nicht nur kassiert. Unter dem Neutrigen hat es jetzt ein bisschen umgedreht. Das heißt, die Balance fehlt da einfach noch so ein bisschen. Und man muss aber auch dazu sagen, dass Oosting vor der Saison keinen Leichtstand hatte, weil einfach auch viele Spieler weggebrochen sind. Also Sam Stein, Stefano, Satellegis, Flapwäck. Das sind bei Twente alles Namen, die eine große Rolle gespielt haben, das ist die Saison. Und die konnten nicht wirklich aufgefangen werden. Sie haben jetzt einen Novica geholt für 6 Millionen, quasi der Königstransfer in dieser Saison bei Twente, Sontre, Earth Yater. Ich hoffe, den Namen wird so ausgesprochen. Es gibt unter den Ligatour-Krämelatoren verschiedenste Aussprache-Varianten. Ja, aber der hat auch noch, links außen, hat in zehn Spielen noch null Tore erzielt. Also das ist so ein bisschen, hat es noch nicht so eingeschlagen, wie man es erhofft hatte. Und gerade mit den Abgängen hat das Ostdingen auch nicht so einfach gehabt. Deswegen kam auch dafür nicht zu früh. Und jetzt muss man schauen, wie es sich entwickelt. Immerhin, die einzelnen Ergebnisse waren jetzt schon wieder auf dem Weg der Besserung. Auch wenn es jetzt nach diesen drei siegenden Folgen wieder ein bisschen gearbeitet hat, zeigen sie sich schon stabil. Wenn der Platz der Bänders 8, den Twente Real hat, zu einem Platz 3 wird, dann zeigt das aber auch, finde ich, das ist ein Indiz dafür, dass die Spiele halt immer zu ungunsten Twentes ausgegangen sind. Ja, dass sie eigentlich im Prinzip schon ihre Chancen hatten, auch unter Ostim-Offensiv, muss man auch sagen, dass sie insofern ihre Chancen schon hatten und eigentlich unterperformen und zwar auch relativ deutlich, zumindest auf diesen X-Ranks, das ist eine nette Spielerei. Auf diesen X-Ranks ist übrigens Ajax auf Platz 9, also auch Ajax, obwohl Ajax stolpert in der Saison, performen sie demnach trotzdem noch über, das ist auch eine nette Rappnotiz.
Quasi die Generation X.
Ja, Generation X.
Also ich lese gerade das aktuelle Buch von Christoph Biermann, die La Tabelle lügt immer und kann euch sagen, es ist eh alles völlig irrelevant, was wir hier tun. Der Zufall hat so einen großen Einfluss im Fußball. Da wir dürften eigentlich gar nicht über Fußball sprechen. So ist das. Also das ist die Situation bei Twente. Ich habe kurz überlegt, ob ich dir helfen kann bei der Aussprache von Oya Zeta. Aber das Name sieht ja schon normal geschrieben so aus, wie die Logos von Bands, die ich gerne höre. Deswegen da bin ich dann tatsächlich auch mal aufgeschmissen. Danke dir, Daniel. Wir schauen noch ein letztes Mal in die Serie A, Christian. Jetzt musst du entscheiden, über was du noch sprechen möchtest.
Ja, dann müssen wir wohl Atalanta auflösen, weil es ja beim letzten Ligatour angesprochen wurde.
Da lobt man einmal Juric.
Genau. Also Ivan Juric ist nicht mehr Trainer von Atalanta seit wenigen Tagen. 0-3 zu Hause gegen Sassuolo wurde ihm zum Verhängnis. Und jetzt haben wir den Punkt. Atalanta hat zwar kaum verloren in der Saison, siebenmal unentschieden gespielt in der Liga, aber hat halt auch kaum gewonnen. Sprich, von elf Ligaspielen haben sie jetzt nur zwei gewonnen, sind Tabellen 13, haben schon neun Punkte Rückstand auf dem Champions League-Platz. Und dementsprechend ist es für Juric jetzt blöd gelaufen. Die letzten zwei Niederlagen in der Liga, jeweils ohne eigenes Tor, haben jetzt dazu geführt, dass er, dass er sich von ihm getrennt wurde. Rafaela Palladino, der Nachfolger, Ex-Fiorentina-Trainer, auch ein Gasparini-Schüler. Sehr spannend, da haben einige schon im Sommer gehofft, dass er das vielleicht übernehmen könnte. Jetzt darf er es mit ein paar Wochen, Monaten Verzug machen. Ja, und zu Juric irgendwie, er hatte Landtag vor kurzem, er hat die Marseille gewonnen in der Champions League, da musste er auch erstmal gewinnen, also so viele gewinnen da nicht. Steht in der Champions League auch gar nicht so schlecht da, gleich viele Punkte wie Barca, gleich viele, sieben Punkte, gleich viele wie Barca, gleich viele wie Chelsea. Und dementsprechend ist ihm jetzt wirklich so, die letzten Spiele in der Liga sind ihm zum Verhängnis geworden. Vielleicht auch ein bisschen atmosphärisch, um es vielleicht kurz zu erklären. Es gab schon einen öffentlichen Disput mit Karnesecki, mit einem Nationaltorhüter, der hat vor wenigen Spielen mal nach dem Spiel gemeint, hey, wer müde ist bei uns, der soll sagen, also wir brauchen mehr Intensität. Da meinte Juric danach, er soll doch bitte weiter Bälle halten und nicht öffentlich reden. Also da hat man so gemerkt, dass intern und Karnesecki hat das wirklich nicht aggressiv formuliert, sondern ich glaube, er wollte einfach ein bisschen Verantwortung übernehmen. Mit Luckmann gab es jetzt in der Champions League eine Auseinandersetzung, wie von den TV-Kameras eingefangen wurde. Also Juric ist wohl nicht mit Alden ganz warm gewesen und deswegen haben sie wohl auch deshalb reagiert und vielleicht von seiner Art, Fußball zu spielen. Ich meine, die Nachfolge von Gasparini bei Atalanta nach neun Jahren zu übernehmen, glaube ich, wäre für jeden sehr schwer gewesen. Die Idee von Atalanta war eben, da jemand zu installieren, der einfach diese Art und Weise, nicht nur fußballerisch, sondern auch vielleicht von der Trainingsintensität einfach fortführt. Aber Juric ist es ganz ein bisschen konservativ angegangen. Und Atalanta, die Spieler in der Mannschaft, die sind es jetzt unter Waren, das unter Gasparini gewöhnt, auch ein bisschen mehr Risiko zu gehen. Und das hat vielleicht nicht so ganz zueinander gepasst. Viele Spiele, finde ich, kann man Juric nicht angreiten. Da haben die Stürmer wahnsinnig viele Chancen liegen lassen. Also Atalanta hätte auch deutlich mehr Spiele gewinnen können als unentschieden. Aber wahrscheinlich war es jetzt atmosphärisch so ein bisschen, dass die Percassis, also die Eigentümer, die Reißleine gezogen haben. Und wie gesagt, Palladino sehr spannend. Mit der Fiorentina letztes Jahr 66 Punkte gemacht. Gasperini, Schüler, ja, vielleicht ist es jetzt der, der dem Ganzen noch ein bisschen mehr Leben einhaucht bei Atalanta. Denn das Spielerpotenzial ist da, hat man auch in der Champions League gesehen. Also ich freue mich auf Palladino.
Und man kann sich, glaube ich, auch auf sein erstes Spiel jetzt dann freuen. Auswärts in Neapel, also das wäre ja so ein Klassiker, wenn jetzt Atalanta da mal wieder das alte Gesicht zeigt. Dann übrigens bei Eintracht Frankfurt, bevor man dann wiederum zu Hause gegen Florenz spricht. Über die können wir jetzt nicht mehr sprechen, aber nur kurz, dass ihr es gehört habt, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Immer noch sieglos am Tabellenende der Serie A werden wir sicherlich in einer der nächsten Folgen dann mal ausführlicher draus schauen. Ihr fünf, ich danke euch sehr, sehr herzlich. Das hat große Freude gemacht, wie immer. Große Runde, viele Themen. Wir haben alles wieder mit dabei gehabt. Herzlichen Dank. Ich sage es jetzt einfach mal so in die Runde an Daniel Zander, Christian Bernhardt, Uli Hebel, David Frogier de Port-le-Voie und Alex Treuker. Vielen, vielen Dank, dass ihr mit dabei wart im Rasenfunk. Danke an dich.
Danke an alle.
Sehr gut. Die alten Reflexe, sie sitzen noch beim David. Und ich danke natürlich auch euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörern, denn ihr wisst ja, alles, was es hier im Rasenfunk gibt, das gibt es nur dank euch. Hier gibt es keine Werbung, keine Sponsoren und vor allem auch keine Paywall. Und wie können wir uns das alles dann leisten? Auch unsere Hörer, Gästehonorare, Entschuldigung, Hörerhonorare gibt es noch nicht. So weit sind wir noch nicht. Da müsst ihr zu Anfang.
Dividende.
Ja, genau. Die Rasenfunk-Dividende, um Gottes Willen. Also, wie ist es möglich, nur dank eurer freiwilligen Unterstützung ganz dividendlos. Und da bedanke ich mich in dieser Folge bei Ulli the Hero, bei Wilmes, bei Klaus Tim, bei Philipp Maria und bei U unterstrich Hoeneß. Es ist aber nicht der und U unterstrich Hoeneß, denn ich kann hier noch sehen, wie sein Klarname ist. In diesem Sinne, danke für eure Unterstützung auf rasenfunk.de. Da erfahrt ihr, wie ihr uns Geld zukommen lassen könnt. Außerdem auch in der Videobeschreibung dieses Videos und natürlich auch in der Podcastbeschreibung dieses Podcasts. Wir sehen einfach alles gleichzeitig. In diesem Sinne, danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Hört auch sehr gerne in andere Folgen des Rasenfunk rein und abonniert mal das Tribütengespräch, denn da wird morgen, wenn alles gut geht, eine Folge erscheinen, die auch mit internationalem Fußball zu tun hat. In diesem Sinne, macht's gut und bis bald. Ciao!
Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen. Vielen Dank!